thank you for joining us America in the
lobby of Ramsey solutions mark and
Nicole are here hey guys how are ya hi
we're so excited to be here
well we're honored to have you welcome
and what are your kids names in ages
this is Cameron and she is 9 and we have
Pierce over there and he is 12 perfect
very cool what are you guys well we live
in Plymouth in units just south of South
Bend Indiana south of South Bend there
we go I love it
well welcome to Nashville and here to do
your debt-free screami' yep how much
have you paid off we paid off two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars and
fourteen months that's crazy-making what
kind of money and this is all business
debts so we have a small business and
the profit for the small business and
that's time frame was about five hundred
thousand oh yeah congratulations per
year um it's growing okay we started
eight years ago
what do you do what kind of business
we're a utility contractor water and
sewer lines and mostly were four
municipalities yeah boom-boom-boom got
some jobs huh yeah Wow congratulations
that's amazing
so it was business death yes there was a
line of credit and three pieces of
equipment heavy equipment what happened
14 months ago that puts you on this
journey made you decide that this was
crazy this has been a long journey Dave
I've listened since my son was about 1
and in 2005 we paid off all our consumer
debt and we started the business in 2007
and we didn't feel like we could do it
without debt and we kind of back pedaled
a little bit but then the business got
rolling we always borrowed money but
we'd pay it right off and we borrow to
get it going and then we pay off and we
had a line of credit and we would borrow
a little bit to pay the bills you know
and but then when we got paid we'd pay
it off so it's kind of like a shell game
almost and then in 2011 we had a really
good year and we paid her home off and
then in a 2014 the end of 2014 I was
just kind of sick of the shell game I
was sick and tired of dealing with the
bank I think I was a sign from God
because every time I went to the bank
they annoyed me and they made mistakes
and I was always correcting them and I'm
like wait a minute no you hope you put
that wrong or that was a principle
payment so we then your job yeah we
could have drew that line in the sand
that we were done we were done with this
and so we I kind of had heard of some
things about you talking
while businesses and so we started
saving more cash we thought okay let's
stop worrying about paying the debt off
so fast because we can't paint it up but
then we'd leave ourselves short to pay
the next bills that came in when the
next job started so we would pay we
decided to pay the line of credit off
and then just stash away cash so
altogether this was a four hundred
thousand dollar turnaround because we
had about fifty thousand and retained
like you know cash reserves and we now
have over two hundred thousand in cash
here's your own line of credit yes
exactly so we closed the line of credit
and then we started chipping away we
went to your when you have the one-day
theater thing the live event that was
recorded in the theaters and we walked
out of there completely pumped up we
were like you know we keep saying we're
debt-free oh yeah we're debt-free except
our business isn't except that little
time yeah yeah except that a little bit
there you know so we said okay we're
done we're gonna and I kind of said well
let's have you know the line of credit
is still you know heavy our own line of
credit and have half the equipment paid
off and Mark came along he's like no no
if we're gonna do this we're going for
it we're gonna have that whole thing
paid off so loved it very cool it's very
cool so really it just can't matter the
principles were there that idea was
there you just had to develop a system
and then you had to both be in agreement
on the system to do it and it really
never was that you were spending the
money on your lifestyle you were just
using it to grow the business faster
than you had money yes yeah and what
really hit me was as we were reading
your book with Rachel and when Rachel's
line in there that says you know but the
credit card jury's looking at your
rear-view mirror mm-hmm and that really
hit me hard I mean when I when I heard
that and and read that that's well
that's what we've been doing this line
of credit and so forth and and mindset
changed and then the the movie last
November mm-hmm and then we just killed
it and yeah very cool that's amazing
guys very very well done congratulations
well it's a big deal just to change your
mindset because it causes you to head to
systems then that applies the principles
and that that makes everything so mark
I've worked with the entrepreneurs and
Nicole long enough that and small
businesses with the entre leadership
stuff that I've seen a thing
I'm pretty regularly where when you
become in the business and everything
completely debt-free you start making
different decisions in the business it's
when I'm dealing with cash I I have this
weird thing I'm more cautious on one
hand but on the other hand I'm more bold
I'm very more bold if I mean it's made
me make my I've made more money because
I'm more bold I I can see myself there
yes yeah I think I think it's going to
cause your income to go out because
you're not dealing with you know you
haven't got this thing in the back of
your mind going Todd if I screw this up
it's gonna take me out you know in fact
if I pay cash for it if I screw it up
money's gone and it's a bad day right
but it doesn't take me out you can
always make more money yeah but it
doesn't it doesn't chase me my mistake
doesn't chase me for the next five years
in the form of payments so I think it
changes the way small business people do
business because we're worse we are
emotionally attached to our debt when
we're in business
more than corporate America doesn't get
that they don't understand there it's a
distant thing to them it's a set of
numbers to them it's not their money
anyway
but when it's us I mean you signed
personally on that line of credit that
line of credit really wasn't I mean it
was a personal line of credit with a
business name on it right so um I mean
you knew that they could come take your
paid for house if you screwed this up
yeah and we're also we deal with you
know performance and performance bonds
oh yeah so you know you're also signing
for that as well yeah I mean it's
there's a lot to it on the line not just
a creditor exactly exactly there's all
kinds of stuff coming at you well
congratulations you guys thanks very
cool I normally ask people you know what
the hardest part was but I hear what you
went through me is it's right there in
front of me and and really you know
let's talk about this way from other
small businesses out there listening
maybe on Terry leadership graduates
those kinds of things out there
listening thinking about in running my
business what would you say the
principles were or what was the things
you learned that caused you to be able
to do this what would you tell them on
how to do this they'd say okay you paid
off 750 grand how to do that we made a
lot of money number one but how'd you do
that kind of thing it's the patient
behind it and be patient as a business
don't grow too fast that I
that's happened before that just about
that was three or four years ago success
can cause you to go broke
yes yeah I mean get too big too fast too
many employees not hiring the right
employees yeah yeah and I mean listening
to you is a great help with the entre
entre leadership podcast it's all I mean
it a lot of some some things relate some
things don't but you can always take
something from it what do you think
Nicole patience is a big thing for me
because you see the money coming I mean
overall I mean this year we're we're in
excess of two million dollars in
contracts so we're gonna bring in and
it's very hard because you see all that
money that needs to go out to pay for
the pipe or pay for the materials and
your payroll but you also see the hall
that receivable but you know you're when
you're looking at just about next month
you're like okay now it needs to hurry
up and get here because I want to pay
these bills I wonder because I want to
go into the next month so that you know
the hardest thing I think was with the
equipment we didn't really ever one we
didn't really want to pay extra on the
bills so we kind of on that debt we we
would have to pile it up and make sure
all our ducks were in a row before we
pulled the trigger to pay that debt off
so we still did them smallest to largest
after we well we took the line of credit
out first cuz that was the most annoying
but the smallest you know equipment debt
and then so it was like okay let's say
the first one was you know it was like
$16,000 so it wasn't as big and I think
the hardest thing it was more of an
emotional no wait
then a financial one which looks kind of
like personal debt with a debt snowball
yeah in a way they're just a little
different weight on it yeah not to make
it sound like it's not a lot of money
cuz it was a massive amount of money
yeah but when you're paying a $2,000
excavator payment it's like okay yeah
but I just paid that supply or $200,000
this month it's you know I mean it's
$1,000 was chump change compared to that
but the emotional burden of if something
ever happened to him I'm gonna have this
excavator set in my front yard not no
you know I would have to move it yeah
yeah really big flowerpot and the cash
is the way the cash needs to flow is you
know we had the money to pay the
excavator off in April but we had to be
sure we had the cash for the for the
year to works all right mark Nicole
Pierce and Cameron
250,000 paid off in 14 months count it
down let's hear a debt free scream 3 2 1
well done well done well done great job
you guys would be so rich so fast and be
able to do so much not only for
yourselves and for your family but for
others